بهانا هل تلوم الرئيس الأسد على
هذا نعم ما هي رسالتك إلى
الرئيس الأسد ، أنا حزين جدًا لأن الكثير
ماتوا ولم يكن لدى أحدهم العالم
يراقب العالم لا يفعل شيئًا
ما تريد أن يفعله العالم أريد  أوقفوا
الحرب وأريد أطفال سوريا
أن يذهبوا إلى المدرسة ويعيشوا بسلام
يمكننا معًا أن نساعدهم في النظر إلى
أنه يمكننا إنقاذهم بهانا عندما
شاهدت الفيديو وصور ما
حدث في سوريا هذا الأسبوع ماذا  هل كنت
تعتقد أنني حزين جدًا لأن 100
سوري قُتلوا في سوريا ، فهم
ليسوا إرهابيين ، لقد كانوا مجرد
أناس ، دعني أسألك أن هذا لم
يبدأ اليوم ، لكن الأمر مستمر منذ
ست سنوات ،
فلماذا تفعل "  هل توقف الحرب
لا أعرف لماذا
لا يستطيع العالم إيقاف الحرب في سوريا دونا هل
تريد أن تكون قادرًا على العودة إلى سوريا
يومًا ما نعم عدن بيتي وأنا أحب
سوريا